[Music]
from Bethlehem to the world Palestinians
say the Christmas message of Hope
started from their small City
they believed that Jesus was born here
more than 2 000 years ago
[Music]
this annual parade tells the Christmas
story and tours different Palestinian
cities
starts the journey from Bethlehem a city
that depends heavily on tourism but it's
taken a hard hit in the past few years
due to the pandemic
we suffered economically because of
covert closures this year is better
because more tourists were allowed in
hopefully it will pick up
a political situation is difficult the
economic situation is even worse but we
are the people of the land and will
remain steadfast in it
Christians used to make up 11 of the
Palestinian population in the 1920s now
they form less than one percent
many here blame the Israeli military
occupation
organizers of the Christmas parade say
it's one way the Palestinian government
is working to keep Christians in their
land
[Music]
this festive mood is one way of
maintaining the Christian presence here
we're also working with the world's
churches to help Christians stay
Israel is doing everything to kick us
out but we counter that to keep
Christian Palestinians in their lands
this Christmas comes after a bloody year
for Palestinians according to the U.N
2022 has been the deadliest in the
occupied West Bank in 16 years the
people here say that this season of Joy
helps them through their struggle
this parade is the result of two months
of work some of the carriages were
brought from abroad but others like this
were made by artists from Bethlehem
the parade has had to take a pause
the day it was supposed to make its way
to the city of Ramallah a general strike
was announced to mourn the death of a
Palestinian prisoner in an Israeli jail
across Palestine people remember the
loved ones they lost this year
more so around the holidays
at Al jazeera's offices this is the
first Christmas without veteran reporter
Shirin
she was killed by Israeli forces while
on assignment in Janine in May
Palestinians take pride that Jesus was
one of them I'd like to celebrate his
birth in the hope that one day
they'll have peace
Ibrahim al-jazeera
occupied West Bank